[Musique]
pour ce concert symphonique le chef
mickaël cousteau a souhaité partir du
son pour aller au clair si pièces sont
prévus au programme dont deux composés
par des femmes est une création de 2020
signée jean baptiste robin à l'origine
devait faire la neuvième de beethoven en
raison de la pandémie on n'a pas pu la
faire parce que c'est trop dangereux de
faire chanter des coeurs et notamment en
allemagne et donc on a remplacé par la
cinquième de beethoven mais toutes les
deux font le même chemin on fait aussi
les 75 ans de paix puisqu'on est dans un
message de réconciliation
franco allemande mais aussi des oeuvres
qui ont été choisis pour être à bord
d'appliquer sous la baguette du chef
d'orchestre près de 80 musiciens
français et allemands tous de moins de
30 ans ils travaillent ensemble depuis
une semaine s'ils ont une approche
différente parce que on n'a pas la même
approche
de leur caisse soit chez les allemands
chez les français les français ont
tendance à être peut-être plus soliste
que en groupe peut jouer ou les
allemands ont cette culture de leur
caisse très très forte on apprend de
jouer ensemble dans leur reste on
apprend à écouter les autres 1 prend
généralement c'est ont fait beaucoup de
la musique dans une semaine et c'est
très intense et moi je tiens toujours
beaucoup de cette expérience c'est la
deuxième édition de cette alliance entre
le conservatoire à rayonnement régional
et l'orchestré des jeunes de la région
de berlin il ya des parties multiples à
la portée artistique bien évidemment du
programme choisi avec le chef
d'orchestre michael busto la portée
humaine évidemment de retrouver enfin
une pratique artistique collective et
puis la portée européenne les jeunes
musiciens jouent le 21 octobre à paris
et le 22 la versailles six dans la cité
royale le concert est déjà complet l'
orchestre pourra vous enchanter dans la
capitale
[Musique]